about 10,000 people along the Louisiana
coast have already been ordered to
evacuate and President Trump declared a
federal emergency for the state last
night CBS this morning lead national
correspondent David Begg know is in
Grand Isle Louisiana where he just spoke
to the mayor David what are conditions
like where you are well Toni it's windy
no rain as of now if you look at where
we are on the map we are at the tip of
Louisiana if you walk off of here you
are swimming in the Gulf of Mexico Grand
Isle is a town in the middle of the Gulf
of Mexico they have been hit really hard
by coastal erosion and the mayor is
worried about what this storm could do
he has ordered a mandatory evacuation
and I just talked to him 10 minutes ago
when a Thai church comes in from the
north side of the island on the backside
and I think he causes severe flooding
and that would put the only Road in and
out of this island under water yes sir
yes sir there are 1400 residents living
in Grand Isle and Mayor David Kammerer
Dale says some of them are not leaving
what would you tell them well right now
the way I'm looking at the ties as we
speak this morning they'd probably be
too late to get off the island
everyone's taking the threat very
seriously Louisianians in low-lying
areas are bracing as the seasons first
expected hurricane loom hopefully
fingers crossed you know and if the
Loess is insane
you know we're survive this one people
are tying up boats stocking up on
supplies prepping sandbags and getting
out but for those who are choosing to
stay behind help people that need help
and ride it out party it up stand for
holding down the fort more than 200
floodgates are now closed surrounding
New Orleans all eyes are on those levees
which were improved following Hurricane
Katrina which devastated New Orleans
between two major bodies of water you
know all of these protecting us with all
the rain the Mississippi River is
expected to crest at 19 feet that's just
a foot below the top of the levees
obviously conditions can change the
residents should stay vigilant and
prepared should should any changes occur
back here in Grand Isle they will
invariably be the first to get hit there
are the levees behind me which protect
the Gulf of Mexico side Grand Isle sits
eight feet below sea level so the mayor
says they'll definitely have flood water
there are 25 pumps here Anthony but you
know where else there are pumps in the
city of New Orleans I was talking to a
woman yesterday in New York headed here
and she said listen David we couldn't
handle a rain shower this week that
flooded our city how is New Orleans
gonna deal with a storm like this given
the fact that the pumps are not
consistently reliable good question
David we're praying for a break down
there thank you